we now have the situation where
Secretary Clinton has said she turned
over all the work-related emails the FBI
has found 14 thousand nine hundred
emails that are work-related
that were not turned over that are going
to the State Department we may see some
of these in the coming weeks before the
election how would you like
14900 of your emails turned over there's
going to be more of a portrait of her
and where it leads is of course one of
the things we don't know and that's it
makes the campaign even more uncertain
and tense particularly for her and her
supporters Bob Woodward what's your take
on all the hacking and of emails here in
Washington that's happening it's clear
there's no privacy I was at a CEO
conference recently and one of the CEOs
of the big tech companies stood up and
said the issue of data protection is
going to be the biggest issue for the
next 20 years and you know when you go
on your iPhone your smartphone your
computer do you have any expectation of
privacy no I mean no reasonable person
would there is all kinds of material out
there clearly the Chinese and the
Russians are hacking so we may have
September October surprised we may have
a surprise every month of the if this
CEO is to be believed then he's somebody
who knows were for the next 20 years
next call for Bob Woodward is Liz in
Arlington Virginia hi Liz were listening
hi Bob Woodward I'm a huge fan of yours
my question is how difficult was it for
you personally to keep the identity of
deep throat a secret for so many years
because we gave our word and when you
give you were
you want to keep it in Carl Bernstein
and Ben Bradley the editor of the post
did finally mark felt it was the number
two in the FBI I think it was 11 years
ago he was 90 at the time decided to
reveal he was that source so he and I
were able to tell that story and in fact
there's a movie that I think will be out
about Mark felt either this year early
next year and so we'll see more of that
detail do you think his reason for being
so called deep throat was personal
patriotic revengeful one of the things
is a reporter as a human being you
realize that there are always multi
reasons and drivers and motives for any
action and in the case of Mark Feld I
think part of it was he wanted the truth
out part of it was he was angry because
he'd been passed over as FBI director
part of it was he knew I think believed
that I would protect that relationship
and the information he gave us I wrote a
whole book about it the secret man felts
book is out in this movie number of
people have written about it or written
books about it but when you look at it
and I knew mark felt in that
relationship and it was never a
relationship where he said okay I'm
gonna come clean I'm going to tell you
everything it was a relationship in
which he controlled the disclosure and
the clues and there was never that kind
of sit-down of hey let let's have a walk
in the park for six hours and tell the
whole story he was not that sort of
person
his very
uptight very concerned that he was going
to be identified very perplexed about
the criminality in the Nixon White House
and so he found a way he wasn't a
volunteer he didn't call me it's
somebody I'd met when I was in the Navy
and I was a past and kept going to him
and so he would provide limited clues
next call for Bob Woodward as Ken in
flora home Florida hi Ken you're on book
TV thank you
I've got your book just began reading it
and I was asked why are there no
photographs in the book well because I
in the back of the book the their
photographs of seven-day documents that
we haven't seen publicly before some of
them top-secret and I thought the
documentation was much more important
than photos of Nixon and Nixon and
Butterfield and there's one on the cover
but you know as we go through this era
of where everyone questions every
institutions politicians candidates
certainly distrust journalists I thought
this was an opportunity to prevent to
present the raw information that is
talked about and discussed in the book
the last of the president's men is the
most recent of Bob Woodward's books
what's the next book I don't know yet
I'm not working on one working on some
things for the campaign coverage I think
finding out exactly what Hillary Clinton
and Trump are who they are what they're
up to is really important I think
there'll be a fabulous book for somebody
about the first year of the next
president is this election unique in
your view are all elections unique yes
but what's what's different about this
one this election and so many things
different five or six months ago a
colleague of mine at the post Bob Costin
I interviewed Trump and we published the
transcript and he said all kinds of
things that really surprised me shocked
many readers he for instance said I
bring out the rage in people he said
that with pride now normally a
presidential candidate would say I'm
going to unify I'm going to bring people
together I'm not going to make him angry
he's quite proud
many times when and I would you know
rage he's happy he brings outrage we
asked him why other Republicans either
succeeded or failed in the presidency
why did Nixon fail and Trump's answer
was well his personality and we had to
say well but the criminality the crimes
and Trump said oh yes those two y bydd
Lincoln's succeed Trump's answer was
well because he did the things that
needed to be done if you know in high
school you wrote that on an exam paper
you wouldn't pass I there is a lot of
history he does not understand but it's
also clear he understands something
going on in the country about the anger
and distress people feel at the elites
at the people who were privileged both
Democrats and Republicans so I think
it's a campaign that has kind of not
just revealed the candidates but
revealed the country let's hear from
Norman in Warren Michigan hi Norman
first of all thank you for all the great
books you've wrote and you've really
done a public service over the years
speaking of mr. Trump does the idea of a
trump presidency scared you as much as
it does me I mean I think of the man as
for lack of a better term as an imbecile
and that I guess that's too harsh of a
word but he clearly suffers from a lack
of a liberal arts background as far as
his statements go all right let's hear
from Bob Woodward I think we got the
point
okay I mean a lot of people agree with
you obviously there are people who
disagree with you in my business what we
really believe in the tradition in habit
of neutral inquiry so the thing I can do
is tell people as much as possible about
him about Secretary Clinton I think
there are key things we don't know like
what's in some of her emails or Donald
Trump's tax returns I hope we're going
to get some information and some
insights before the campaign you say am
I scared I don't know I mean the the
presidency has withstood all kinds of
people and we have a democracy if Trump
wins we're going to all have to deal
with it I suspect this is a text message
and this is from Ken in Ithaca New York
Woodward and Bernstein did investigative
work no longer done by the traditional
press it is now done by fringe groups
like WikiLeaks what has changed well but
that's just not true my own newspaper of
The Washington Post has done a whole
book on Trump David Ferran Thal has done
some magnificent investigation of trumps
charities the deductions how he used the
charity allegedly to pay off all kinds
of things that were personal that's not
what a found a
is four so I think there's some great
work done again I think we need to know
more text message what was the
relationship between President Nixon and
wife path in the last of the president's
men Butterfield Nixon's aide was
assigned the Pat Nixon account and he
describes in detail how she was kind of
the abused wife and Nixon wouldn't talk
to her wouldn't consult her there's some
scenes that are the saddest I've ever
written about Nixon and Butterfield and
Pat Nixon flying in the helicopter Pat
Nixon says to her husband dick we need
to go up to New York over Christmas
let's have a good time with the girls
and Nixon totally ignores her sticks
with his yellow legal pad and she keeps
at it and Butterfield just said that you
know he almost wanted to reach over and
Nick's aunt Nixon and grab him and say
hey you sob answer her next call for Bob
Woodward is Kerry in Hill City South
Dakota hi Kerry hi this is a pleasure
you have no idea how glad I am to talk
to Bob Woodward my question for you is
very simple when you and Carl were
working on the Watergate thing did you
either one of you realize that you're
probably unraveling one of the greatest
mysteries in American history well there
were stages and it was over a two-year
period and we felt we had good
information and good sources but
remember people didn't believe it Nixon
beat George McGovern in 72 after we'd
written most of these stories and Nixon
beat McGovern it was a landslide people
I think the sense that the president was
a criminal and would
order and carry out all of these illegal
and abusive action seemed impossible so
it was story after story we wrote
hundreds of stories in the end and it
was the Senate Watergate committee the
house impeachment inquiry the Watergate
prosecutor who really dug into this and
eventually developed the documentation
testimony and secret tape recordings Bob
Woodward who is still alive from the
Nixon White House from the House
Judiciary Committee etc oh that's a good
question
Alexander Butterfield sander Butterfield
is one of the few John Dean John Dean is
who was Nixon's counsel who testified so
dramatically in 73 four days about his
dealings with Nixon and the crimes and
and the cover-up you know there are a
few people but the main aides are gone
Henry Kissinger is still alive he is a
figure in this book I think there is
still work to be done
on the Vietnam War and why Nixon
continued that war when he had the
opportunity when he became president in
69 to change the policy he withdrew
troops but increased the bombing so
what's the bottom line what's the lesson
history is never over there's always
work to be done and this is a text
message from 956 area code reminder if
you send a text message include your
first name and city mr. Woodward who is
the most honest politic politician you
have researched I found in the end
Gerald Ford who pardoned Nixon and I
thought the pardon was a corrupt act and
I examined in detail and interviewed
Ford many times
and actually what Ford did rather than
it being a deal or an act of corruption
was a very courageous act to pardon
Nixon and Watergate if Nixon had not
been pardoned he was going to be
investigated
certainly in excuse me indicted tried
baby go to jail so we'd have two or
three more years of Watergate miss Ford
said to me in a very plaintive way I
needed my own presidency when's the last
time you sat down with Gerald Ford
before he died it was several months
before I think and one of the things he
told me which we published in The
Washington Post after he died Ford said
if he'd been president he would not have
been baited Iraq his President George
Bush did John is calling in from Naples
Florida John you're on with author Bob
Woodward how are you a huge fan for many
years I wanted to ask you please
continuing that Donald Trump dialogue
what is your take on what I see now just
published for the first time yesterday
in Yahoo News and I see this morning in
the Washington Post and The New York
Times the involvement of this Carter
page with Donald Trump and Putin and
just a lot going on there than perhaps
Trump chooses to dismiss and who are you
voting for us we could ask but your
opinion of Carter page Trump this
alignment with Russia and really Trump
working in the answerest potentially of
Russia rather than the United States in
this election
I don't know that specifics but I think
there are a lot of unanswered questions
about Trump's dealings in Russia and
with Putin and that's one of the reasons
to get his tax returns that there may be
some insight there in terms of who I'm
voting for I don't vote I kind of think
that it's
important that reporters who work on
these candidates and the issues and
presidents extract themselves from
reaching personal conclusions and if you
vote or you allow yourself with one side
or the other it adds to the suspicions
about the neutrality of the press which
i think is a giant issue in this
campaign and in the country right now
executive editor len downey of the post
did that correct that's correct he he
didn't vote for my I used to vote and
take my young daughter into the polling
booth with me and let her decide and
told her and she was empowered to vote
for me they let you do that in the
District of Columbia but now she's off
in college and so I'm alone and I
literally am NOT gonna vote ok back to
mark felt Bob Woodward did you write it
down anywhere did you put it in a safety
deposit box did you tell your wife your
parents anyone yes I told my wife Elsa
Walsh of course years ago Ben Bradlee
knew Carl Bernstein knew before felt
disclosed that his identity in 2005 knew
he was getting old very senile and so I
wrote the book that became the secret
man did the first draft of it at that
point and had Ben Bradley go through it
I had my wife go through it had my
editor go through it so it was not good
it's important vitally important that
that not be an unanswered question about
Watergate text message area code five
six one mr. Woodward what do you think
about the Clinton Foundation I think the
Clinton Foundation is one of these money
stories that we
my newspaper of the Washington Post has
done some wonderful in-depth work about
the foundation I think there are
unanswered questions I think when
Secretary Clinton says there was no
conflict I mean it was a walking
breathing living conflict at the same
time in her favor and in Bill Clinton's
favor the Clinton Foundation has done a
lot of very good and important work that
other people wouldn't do but again it's
like emails and Trump's tax returns we
don't know the whole story there I hope
there's in fact more information about
the foundation about the speeches about
all the money making by both candidates
before the vote
let's get Steve in Alexandria Virginia
in before we have to close go ahead
Steve insight into the relationship
between dick Nixon and former President
George HW Bush Senior that's an
interesting question
of course Bush Senior was head of the
Republican National Committee was
chairman during Watergate that was her
duty and Bush had to go around and
defend Nixon and at the end he was one
of the people who words that Nixon
resigned so it was not a very close
relationship and I think it's one of the
examples Nixon built this web any
intrepid people and Bush was one of
those people who was given the
responsibility and soldiered on through
it but at the same time I know when I
did books on the first Gulf War when
Bush Senior was President Bush senior
would never
that would never be interviewed I think
the lingering memory of Watergate was
too large Bob Woodward Bob Woodward comm
if you want to get the full list of all
of his 17 or 18 books his most recent
the last two the president's men an
interview and insight into Alexander
Butterfield there's the cover thanks for
being on book TV thank you if you like
presidential history there is another
new book that's coming out and it's the
paperback version of the first lady's
book you might remember that c-span did
a series just recently on all the first
lady's it was in the last two years or
so came out with a hardback book at that
point but the paperback version is
coming out you can pre-order it on your
websites beginning tomorrow but it's
also available at your favorite
booksellers first ladies presidential
historians on on the lives of 45 iconic
American women this is the paperback
version so it'll be available beginning
tomorrow well coming up several more
hours of live coverage from the National
Book Festival here in Washington DC in
just a minute representative John Lewis
will be out here to take your calls and
talk about his National Book Award
nominated book March part 3 this is
about his civil rights career and what
he did to influence that period of time
he'll be out here in just a minute but
it's a busy day here in Washington
earlier this morning representative
Lewis spoke at the opening of the new
National Museum of african-american
history and culture want to show you a
little bit about of what he had to say
and now you're free Bob
this is a great achievement I tell you I
feel like singing the song my hated
Jackson song at the march on Washington
over fifty years ago how we got over how
we got over there was some who said it
couldn't happen who said if they do it
but we did it we did it we're gathered
here today to dedicate a building but
this place is more than a building it is
a dream come true you and I each and
every one of us were caught up in a seed
of light we were a vision born in the
minds of life's the War veterans and
their supporters they met right here in
Washington DC in 1916 exactly 100 years
ago the 19th Street Baptist Church still
in existent today oh they're all fair
see for the dream can do you could roll
up the sleeves of those veterans at
restorable on their backs you might find
the wounds or shackles and quips moles
cannot read the Declaration of
Independence or write their own names
but in their hearts burn endure envision
of true democracy that no threat of
death the ever erase the understood the
meaning of that contribution they set a
possibility in motion passed and down
through the ages from heart to heart and
breath to breath that we had given birth
today to this museum is a testament to
the dignity of a dispossession
in every corner of the globe who young
for freedom it is a song to the scholars
and pride scientists and teachers to the
revolutionary and a voices of protests
to the ministers in the office of peace
it is the story of life the story of our
lives wrap up in a beautiful golden
crown of grace I can hear the distant
voice of ancestors whispering by the
night fine still away he still the way
home
we ain't got long to stay here a big
bowl quiet shot in I woke up this
morning with my mind stayed on freedom
all their voices roaming for century
have found to find their home here in
this great monument top pain I'm
suffering in our victory when I was a
little child growing up in rural Alabama
the short walk to the cotton fields but
hundreds of miles from Washington from
the Washington Monument or the Lincoln
Memorial my teachers would tell us that
cutout photographs the pictures a great
african-american for ecology was since
Negro History Week not called African
American History Month I became inspired
by the stories of George Washington
Carver Jackie Robinson Rosa Parks and so
many others who live and work would be
enshrined in this museum as these doors
open it is my hope that each and every
person who visit this beautiful museum
will walk away deeply inspired be able
for greater respect but the dignity and
the worth of every human being and a
stronger commitment to the ideal of
justice equality and true democracy
thank you and now joining us here live
at the National Book Festival is
Congressman John Lewis and his co-author
Andrew iDEN here is the book March book
3 it's been nominated for a National
Book Award congressman Lewis what period
of time does this book cover well this
book cover the latter part of my own
involvement in the American civil rights
movement that part that's stored with
right after the march on Washington the
bombing of the Church in Birmingham from
that took place on September 15 1963
well full of girls was killed the
assassination of President Kennedy
the beginning of the cell movement
Mississippi Freedom Summer
so it's sixty three six two four six two
five it was some of the most dramatic
points in American civil rights movement
there was so much violence there were so
many beatings some people were murdered
but they never gave up they never gave
in it's a period of sorrow but it's also
a period it's a period of people believe
in and hanging in there young people
people not so young like people white
people coming together literally put it
at body's own on the line we witnessed
the passage of the Civil Rights Act the
Voting Rights thing and a lot of the
signs that we have seen and witnessed
came coming in and down into iDEN why
graphic novel form for this book I think
we were trying to reach another
generation and this generation is a
they're digital natives and so they
speak in sequential storytelling that's
how they understand information and so
for me I was a lifelong comics fan and
when the congressman told me about a
comic book called Martin Luther King in
the Montgomery story that was published
in 1957 sold for ten cents and when I
found out that it actually been edited
by Martin Luther King jr. himself and
used to inspire some of the earliest
acts of civil disobedience it seemed
almost self-evident we had to do it
we're gonna put the phone numbers up on
the screen so you can get start calling
for representative John Lewis and his
co-author Andrew hidin 202 is area code
7 4 8 8200 for those of you in the east
and central time zones seven four eight
eight two zero one for those of you in
the mountain and Pacific time zones now
we've got a third number you can get
through two on it is not for phone calls
it is for text messages only and that is
202 eight three eight six two five one
again text messages only and please
include your first name and your city
congressman Lewis we're talking about
March 3 and the African American Museum
is opening up today
well the opening of this museum tell a
powerful story it's the history of
African American from the days of
slavery to the present I have had an
opportunity to walk through this museum
I cried and even today I shared it some
tears there was a sea of humanity on
them all you know that the museum is
located on what I call the front porch
of America and we were sitting there on
the front porch of the museum and one of
the reason that we insisted that that
there be a front porch because in
American South African American would
come and it was take seats on a Saturday
afternoon a sunny afternoon on the front
porch of the house or their homes and I
think this museum will be visited by
hundreds and thousands and millions of
people from all over America and from
around the world
so this museum is not just a story of
African American it's an American story
it is sorrows are pain but it's also our
victors
Andrew Aydin how do you put a day like
today and working with representative
John Louis how do you put that into
context I've served on the congressman's
congressional staff for ten years a
decade now and one of the things I've
seen is how the congressman doesn't
simply look at things as a short-term
objective he always has the long view
and sometimes those long-term projects
all come together on a single day and so
to see that the National Museum of
african-american history and culture
open on the day where he's going to the
National Book Festival and talking about
another project that he's doing it is
part of the same mission educating
everyone on what happened and how it
happened during the civil rights
movement it's a part of his DNA it's a
part of his mission because if we don't
understand what happened during the
Civil Rights Movement
we cannot understand the politics of
today and at the time everybody thought
it was a long shot for him to get this
museum pass through the Congress but
also everyone thought it was a long shot
for him to even try and do a graphic
novel but here we are on a single day
showing that long shot ideas and John
Lewis's persistence can work and change
this country what's your background you
know probably not the same as
congressman Louis's no I'm he's been my
congressman since I was three years old
I was raised by a single mother my
father was Atlanta in Atlanta and my
father was a Turkish immigrant who came
to this country and then actually left
my father left my mother when I was very
young and and part of that's how I got
into comic books but I'd always been a
little bit of a rabble rouser I you know
you see your mother you see a single
mother being treated the way they are in
America particular in the 70s and 80s
you can't help but ask yourself when you
grow up what can I do to make it better
so that other people don't have to watch
their parents suffer that way and that
developed my own social consciousness it
made me want to be a part of public
service I didn't necessarily want to go
and just make widgets I wanted to be a
part of our national conversation so
that other parents would have it a
little bit easier and there's no
person who work for if that's your goal
than John Lewis congressman Lewis to
people who feature in March buck three
George Wallace and Lyndon Johnson did
you ever sit down with George Wallace as
the governor Wallace was no longer
governor I had an opportunity to sit
down with him and talk with him he heard
that I was going to be near Montgomery
about 50 miles away outside of a little
town called Troy where I grew up
and he invited me and made arrangements
for me to come and see him and we had a
wonderful discussion and we came to that
point he was talking about what happened
in Selma on the bridge in 1965 and I
asked him I said governor why did you
get an order for the troopers to stop us
to beat us and he said John there were
people on the other side of the bridge
they were going to kill you
as the governor Perdue's almost kill
people kill other people that keep
someone else from killing then and that
we had a right to march from Selma to
Montgomery
you know orderly peaceful nonviolent
fashion and he said I didn't mean for
them to hurt you and he said you know I
love everybody I have a lot of life
friends and again I had an opportunity
as I've decided to take members of
Congress back to Alabama to Montgomery
to Selma to Birmingham and we were in
Montgomery and his son inform us that
governor Wallace we're at home in his
bed he was paralyzed and he wanted us to
come by and see him and he was laying up
in his bed smoking a cigar watching the
Wallace story on TNT and we walked in
and some of the guys especially from the
north members of Congress
they were reluctant to shake his hand
he's seen in the photograph and so I
just grabbed him by the hand
say hello governor how are you he's a
good to see you and then they all came
in and shook his hand and we took
pictures with him let's hear from our
callers let's begin with Margie and
Pratt West Virginia Margie
representative John Lewis and Andrew
Aydin are our guests the book is March 3
March book 3 well I have to tell you I'm
absolutely thrilled to talk to you mr.
Lewis
I just it's wonderful to get to see a
hero in our own living time period and I
want to thank you for everything she do
for civil rights and rights in general
two questions if I may please I wanted
to ask this one of mr. Woodward and I
couldn't get in on time but what are
your concerns about Donald Trump's
president see your main concerns if he
were to be elected and my second
question is I've been a Democrat my
whole life I'm 64 years old I'm I don't
feel like I have a voice in my party
because of the abortion issue is there
something that you see that we can do to
help women not have to go in that tragic
direction and because I feel like tell
you what I think we got the first part
of your question a Donald Trump
presidency representative well I don't
want to see mr. Trump but become
president first of all I don't think
he's qualified I think he has a mean
spirit and he want to take us back to
another period I think his presidency
would divide America will come so far we
made so much progress and we will must
steal make progress we must lay down the
burden erase the burden the division and
create one community one family and it
doesn't matter for little black or white
Latino Asian American and Native America
we all live in the same house the
American house or the world house and we
must learn to live together
as brothers and sisters as dr. King said
if not we repairs as fools and ridin
colin kaepernick kneeling during the
star-spangled banner i think it's a
powerful statement and what we're seeing
is other people taking part as well he's
inspired something i think something's
happening in america you know when we
started march in 2013 we almost jokingly
said that all this has happened before
and all of this will happen again and we
had no way of knowing how right we were
and i think he's a key part of bringing
non-violence of bringing civil
disobedience of bringing protests to
young people so that they can in fact be
the reinforcements part of what we're
trying to do is to show that young
people were the driving force in many
ways of the civil rights movement and
that they were the key component in
pushing some of the most important
reforms that the civil rights movement
achieved and i think if he's able to
inspire young people to participate to
speak up and speak out then he's doing
this nation a great service next call
for our guest comes from cameron in
Gaithersburg Maryland Cameron go ahead
hi representative Lewis it's an honor to
talk to you I'm a student at the
University of Maryland Baltimore County
our President Freeman hrabowski was very
involved in the in the civil rights
movement and my question for you is what
advice do you have for people who are
involved in the black lives matter
movement well I was said and thank you
so much I know your president is a
wonderful young man he was very much
involved in the city in Birmingham
during the what I like to call the
children crusade I would say to the
young people involve and a black lives
matter movement and to all young people
and it doesn't matter for theya black or
white Latino Asian American or Native
America when you see something that is
not right not fair not just you have a
mall a vacation to do something about it
but do it in a peaceful organized
nonviolent fashion
and stand up and speak up and speak out
when I was growing up I will ask my
mother and my father my grandparents my
great grandparents about segregation and
racial discrimination the signs that I
saw and they were said don't get in
trouble don't get in the way that's the
way it is but I was inspired to get in
trouble good trouble necessary trouble
that's what all young people have an
obligation and a responsibility to do
August 6 1965 I was invited to meet
privately with the president in the Oval
Office the morning before the Voting
Rights Act signing ceremony this was my
first visit to the White House since the
march on Washington and my first
one-on-one visit with the president's
Wow John you got to go back and get all
those folks registered and you got to go
back and get those boys by the balls
just like a bull gets on top of a cow
you've got to get them by the balls and
you got to squeeze squeeze them till
they hurt are these direct quotes from
President Johnson President Johnson was
very colorful very unbelievable he spoke
in a very plain and simple fashion and
sometime you'd be at listen to him you
smile you want to laugh but you wanted
to be respectful of the President of the
United States but he was making it plain
he was making it clear and you were
prepared to go out and do what he
suggested and that's what we tried to do
get everybody register to vote in Dryden
who's Nate Powell Nate Powell I believe
is one of the finest graphic novelists
of his generation
he's from little North Little Rock
Arkansas he lives in Bloomington now and
he's our artists on on this book he he's
like a brother we're sorry we he's not
here today but he's home he's got two
little girls and so he's been good he's
been on the road with us and touring and
working as hard as as anybody on this
team could well we've got a call from
Midland Georgia this is Fred hi Fred how
you doing John Lewis
very proud of you with your your life
history but my question is and in
reference to your book cause I have all
three of your books why can't we have a
national March for what's going on in
today's world with all the resources we
have now and uh and how fast the country
is not motivated to do something about
white black and everyone why can't we
have a march on Washington now with you
and other civil rights leaders leaving
but I think that best march that we can
have right now in America its own
Election Day November the 8th for all of
us
all over America black and white Latino
asian-american Native America and young
people the march to the polls the vote
is precious
it's almost sacred it is the most
powerful nonviolent tool we have an
undemocratic society so let's go to the
vote let's go out and vote you know dr.
King was safe sir can't crawl maybe if
she can't run crawl but somehow make it
there just go to the polls and vote
that's going to be the best march we can
have it this time rich in battleground
Washington Texan do you have a sense of
optimism about race in our country going
forward I am very very optimistic very
hopeful that we're going to lay down a
burden a race and we're gonna create for
dr. king called a Beloved Community
well we will respect the dignity and a
word that every human being and we will
get there we will get there and when we
get there we will serve as a model for
the rest of the world I truly believe
sometimes people tell me that nothing
has changed I feel like saying come and
walk in my shoes and I would show you
change Elizabeth in Denver Colorado hi
Elizabeth
hi mr. Lewis this is truly an honor my
mother lived in Mississippi during the
time of Emmett Till and I know I don't
have to explain that to you I'd like to
know
what advice you have for the young
people today that are really struggling
with the black lives movement and all
the police violence because it's hard
for them they feel disenfranchised and
I'd like to know what what advice you
have for them to feel more included but
to be less violent well thank you so
much I tell you I grew up in rural
Alabama and I'm social circle Gatien and
racial discrimination and I remember so
well August 28th
when Emma teal was Lynch I saw the
pictures I read about it and today I had
an opportunity to visit the
african-american museum what a cancer or
immaterial is now located I said to the
young people never become bitter
never become hostile never to hate hate
is too heavy a burden to bear
be hopeful be optimistic and never ever
get lost in a sea of despair work
together and pull together and we will
change America and we will take America
to a better place
representative Louis I didn't realize
Emmett Till was killed on August 28th
was there a connection between that and
the fact that the march on Washington
was on August 28th I believe some of the
planners some of the people had that
date in mind you know in 1955 was also
the beginning of the Montgomery bus
boycott and Rosa Parks different people
answer why did you do it why did you
keep your seat she said that she
couldn't get out she couldn't get it she
said she was not time she said I also
thought about what had happened to
Emmett deal next call comes from a place
called Troy Alabama and this is Jesse in
Troy hi Jesse hi Chester how are you
Luis yes sir you were raised right here
with my mother and my grandmother stuff
may impact County yeah I know you very
well and I just like what you're doing I
appreciate what you're doing my question
to you is what do you think about what's
going on in Charlotte and the other
places witness police brutality it's
killing a black young man well thank you
thank you so much for your call I'm very
sad about what is happening in Charlotte
North Carolina
what happened in Oklahoma and other
parts of our country but police officers
and young people and all of us must come
together and talk to each other never
hate each other
we need more what I call community
policing maybe police officers along
with young people and people are not so
young should study the way of peace the
way of love the philosophy and the
discipline of non-violence
during his 60s I was arrested in jail
beaten and left bloody but I never gave
up and never became bitter and when I
see a young police officer all the
police officers were they
african-american for the day a white a
Latino asian-american always said thank
you for your service they are out to
protect us and protect a society and it
was very moving to see the young
demonstrators in Charlotte North
Carolina shaking hands and hugging the
National Guardsmen enter ID holder you
in your 30s 33 and so you didn't live
during the era of March no when you
think about what's going on today and
what you've learned about this period in
our history what are your thoughts well
I think in some ways there's a there's a
bright light in the fact that we're
actually seeing many of these killings I
don't think they're happening in
isolation I don't think they just
started I think they've been happening
for quite some time but because of the
ubiquitous nature of camera phones and
technology we're able to record these
incidences and they can't be swept under
the rug anymore and I think the first
step towards dealing with them is
acknowledging that they're there and
finally we're able to have a national
conversation around it and my hope is
that that spurs organizing protesting
and ultimately action on the part of our
elected officials for me
growing up in the congressman's district
growing up in in Georgia
I heard about the civil rights movement
I saw some parts of it but I never had
the opportunity to hear the story of
snick of the young people and so what I
was constantly trying to do was to tell
the stories that I heard John Lewis say
and make them meaningful and important
so that my generation could understand
what sacrifice it took to get the
progress that they achieved well we've
got a call from another city that John
Lewis is connected to and this is will
in Atlanta hi will
I appreciate you taking my call hey
congressman looking back all these years
after getting you elected on the top
radio Sunday morning with Ike and
whatnot I'm grateful but it turned out
the way it did given the scandals had
followed that would have happened
publicly afterwards as you well know
what I'm talking about but the fact that
matter is voting is not almost sacred
it's sacred elect means chosen of God
and there 18 forms of the word elect
comprise the spine of the Constitution
and we as a nation were founded and
expressed covenant with the creator of
the universe the deity God Almighty
there is no question about it
there may be multiple parties but
there's only one God and we know that if
you're not serving truth and justice one
is not serving God our sovereign will in
Atlanta this is a text message from Liz
in New York City
mr. Lewis a few words about shirley
Chisholm well I met shirley Chisholm
years ago she was a brave and courageous
woman but she came to Congress they put
her on the AG committee to our cultural
committee and I represent in Brooklyn
but she she served sister well and she
tried to help get food for starving
people in in the south and rural America
in Virginia in Kentucky
all over the place and she was the first
woman to get out there and get a name on
the ballot to run for president and
let's take another call we have time for
a couple more calls and of course I have
lost my place in this modern technology
I will work my way back in two seconds
but while we're while I'm trying to find
where I'm supposed to be on this phone
nomination for a National Book Award
how'd you find out it's not glamorous I
showed up at work about my day and when
I booted up the computer all of a sudden
I had all these messages and somebody
was like did you see did you see and I
got a request for comments and all these
different things and I'm like what are
these people talking about and so I
finally had to go to look at the website
and I sort of backed away from my desk
and I was like what has just happened
and that's how I found out and then I
got to call the congressman and tell him
you'll be in New York for the ceremony
well yeah I think so you know we should
be there if we make we make the lives if
we make there four finalists will be
there will be there and you know we both
have a day job but for something like
this we will sort of leave that day job
and we'll make it to New York
Martin is calling in from Bernie Texas
hi Martin how do you do congressman I
would just like to ask a question I'm
originally from Chicago live there 70
years in fact my uncle built the
original Chicago Stadium where FDR gave
his inaugural now my question is I've
seen Chicago deteriorate to the point
that it's embarrassing to the nation I
live in Texas for 12 years now however
my question to you is what happens in a
morality of the blacks in America
there's so many beautiful blacks like
you and so many including the president
who's half white but they never mention
that but I'm saying whoever mentions the
fact that the duration of the family and
what's the excuse for that you have all
the people there at the congressional
representatives the Oprah Winfrey's are
made as my maid away in Chicago how do
you explain it sir and I'll only ask one
all right let's hear the answer to that
question Martin well let me sister thank
you so much for your call but there many
african-american in Chicago and the
other major urban centers and in small
towns and rural communities all across
America are doing very very well but
there's some people in our society that
have been left out and left behind and
they're not just African American but in
white America that Latinos they're Asian
American and Native America as a country
and as a people we must see that all of
our citizens lifted up and that they
have the Grace and the support to move
ahead but we must see that all of our
children receive the best possible
education receive great health and good
healthcare text message I am a history
teacher in Richmond Virginia I have
taught civil rights using your book it
is an excellent resource I let students
know that this was a movement by young
people what else do we need to do to
combat youth apathy
I think we have to help people help
young people ask the fundamental
questions that they were asking during
the movement one of the things I like to
ask students when we go out into the
schools and into the communities what
would dr. King tweet poet Gandhi posts
on Facebook how would they use these
tools now I serve as the congressman's
digital director so in a sense I'd tweet
for a living but for these young people
they have at their fingertips the
capacity to organize on a scale never
before seen on the face of this planet
and so if we can put them in the context
of what these great leaders had to go
through and then ask them how would they
use the tools of today to achieve the
same results and I think that
empowerment will help them feel like
it's not out of touch it's not out of
reach and that apathy isn't something
that should be available to them that
they have the capacity and they have the
necessity and that they must act I think
it's important to young people to
understand I was a reach reach March
reach read my story but also come in and
visit places all across America come to
the african-american Museum and walk
through these pieces of history
they should be inspired they should be
able to feel and say if another
generation can do for that before people
did I too can do something I too can
make the contribution and was deeply
inspired by Rosa Parks and more Luther
King jr. I met Rosa Parks when I was 17
I met morton's the King jr. when I was
18 met President Kennedy for number 23
and worked in by Barry Kennedy's
campaign all these people helped make me
the person that I am today so you've got
a lot of people here at the National
Book Festival watching you right now
congressmen saw a bunch of young people
here as well what do you tell them I
tell them that when they shake your hand
because their parents want to welcome
each I would say good to see you thank
you for being here and I am
you know I love you the sustain school
get the best possible education that you
can yet be hopeful be optimistic and be
happy don't get lost enough sleeve to
span here's the book
March book 3 John Lewis Andrew Aydin and
Nate Paul as the illustrator nominated
for a National Book Award this is again
book 3 representative Lewis and Android
and have written two other